comme vous le savez il y a eu le G7 à
Biaritz en 2019 c'est ce qui a été fait
c'est ce qui a été fait il y avait une
plateforme d'enregistrement pour les
riverins de manière à pouvoir justifier
de l'accès au périmètre de mémoire
d'ailleurs à biarit ça concernait aussi
les piétons je rappelle que je ne parle
que de la circulation routière
automobile automobile voilà il nous
paraissait plus simple de prévoir une
plateforme avec justificatif papier QR
code comme j'ai pu le dire dans Le
Parisien moi j'en sais rien on va en
discuter dans la concertation ver ce que
veulent les gens en général les gens
préfèrent quand même les QR codes parce
que ça permet au contrôle de flasher et
les gens passent on tout ça on en
discutera en tout cas nous nous
considérons d'un point de vue
sécuritaire que ce périmètre de toute
façon est indispensable à mettre en
place nous considérons d'un point de vue
de la bonne tenue des JO et que pour les
gens puissent continuer à vivre
normalement qu'il doit y avoir des
dérogations et évidemment le triangle de
tout ça c'est qu'on puisse contrôler et
la sécurité et le le le le fait que ces
dérogations soient rigoureusement
appliqué bon voilà donc voilà d'où
l'idée de cette plateforme qui en droit
puisque c'est une question qui qui m'a
été posée hier euh j'ai j'ai entendu
donc des comparaisons avec l'état
d'urgence il faut une loi et cetera bon
tout tout le monde se souvient que
l'état d'urgence c'était quand même des
contraintes qui étaient d'un autre
niveau d'un autre niveau on était sur
des mesures où vous deviez rester à
votre domicile euh avec des des
contrainte pénale pénale moi la
contrainte qu'il y a à mes périmètres de
circulation c'est que vous rentrez pas
hein c'est c'est tout vous garez votre
voiture et vous rentrez à pied hein donc
avec des contraintes pénales une série
de mesures qui étaient beaucoup plus
restrictives il ne sagissa il ne
s'agissait pas de il ne s'agissait pas
évidemment de de de d'un simple une
simple restriction le fait de pénétrer
en véhicule dans une zone et puis l'état
d'urgence c'était une mesure qui était
évidemment applicable sur l'ensemble du
territoire national là on ne parle que
de quelques zones dans Paris évidemment
dans l'ensemble de la région
Île-de-France autour des autres sites
mais ailleurs qu'à Paris l'impact est
moindre hein il faut faut j'ai oublié de
préciser ça c'est très important à Paris
l'impact est important parce qu'il y a
des sites éphémères qui vont avoir une
surface plus importante